Carrie Fisher's daughter played a much
bigger role in the rise of Skywalker
than you might think
after Fisher suddenly passed away from a
heart attack in December 2016 director
JJ Abrams and the team behind the rise
of Skywalker were left with a unique
challenge how could they incorporate
Fisher's iconic character general leia
organa without the actress through some
clever cgi tricks and a performer
capable of following in Fishers
footsteps the impossible became possible
unbeknownst to most to Billie law to
appear in the force awakens and the
rights of Skywalker as junior
communications coordinator lieutenant
Kade Orko conics also made an appearance
in the final film of the Skywalker saga
as a young Leia during a crucial scene
where the princess turned general Leia
trained in the ways of the force in an
interview with Yahoo visual effects
supervisor Patrick two-buck confirmed
though ball Mark Hamill went through a
tee aging process to look like a younger
Luke Skywalker Lourdes stepped in to
play leia rumors swirled for months the
Lord whose lieutenants conic sports
layer signature buns strung her
appearances on screen would be playing a
young layer at some points during the
rites of Skywalker now to Barker's
confirmed those series those lost face
isn't actually used in the final product
it's a CGI rendering of what fish look
like in a youth everything else of a
physical form is he said Billy was
playing her mother it was a poignant
thing and something that nobody took
lightly that she was willing to stand in
for her mom it was an emotional thing
for everybody to see her in that
position it felt great for us to if
you're going to have someone play fixes
parts it's great that as Billy because
there are a lot of similarities between
them that we were able to draw from the
real challenge was just making the layer
footage we had to work with fit in the
scene the effects supervisor Roger
guyot's also told Yahoo what you see is
what we developed the idea was to
provide this great surprise where they
take the helmets off and you see Luke
and Leia's younger faces we scoured
outtakes from the original movies and we
took some pieces and then had to try and
figure out the technical aspect of
putting that shot together going forward
whether or not Slayer appears in any
future Star Wars projects will be
entirely up to the young actress as
Guyot noted the truth is that Carey was
a friend of JJ and Billy as a friend of
JJ they talked a lot about us and I
think the heart of it is that most
respect for Carey and her memory and her
performance it
couldn't have been easy for Lord who
lost both their beloved mother and her
grandmother Debbie Reynold's before 2016
came to an end to step in and play her
mother in the build-up to rise of
Skywalker Lord even addressed the legacy
of both her mother and Leia by penning a
deeply emotional essay for Time magazine
where she discussed the good and bad
impact that Princess Leia had on her
life initially Lord was confused and
often irritated by her mother's fame but
eventually she came around she rose I
realized then the layer is more than
just a character she's a feeling she is
strength she is Grace she is wit she is
femininity at its finest she knows what
she wants and she gets her she doesn't
need anyone to defend her because she
defends herself and no one could have
played her like my mother Princess Leia
as Carrie Fisher Carrie Fisher as
Princess Leia the two go hand in hand
Lord then concluded the essay by saying
I grew up with three parents a mom a dad
and Princess Leia initially Princess
Leia was kind of like my stepmom now
she's my guardian angel and I'm her
keeper
regardless of whether Lord takes on the
role of layer in a future Star Wars film
he's got an undoubted Lee bright future
ahead of her after gaining fame and
acclaim thanks to her various roles on
Ryan Murphy's anthology series American
Horror Story Lord made her mark on the
big screen in Olivia Wilde's directorial
debut book smarts playing the absurd
scene-stealing character GG if Lord
chooses to retire her mother's signature
character after the rise of Skywalker
this is a comforting relief for many
fans to get even a brief glimpse of this
beloved character and in the end nobody
else could have played Leia quite like
Lord check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
buy your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]